This brings us to Branch Prediction Requirements.
What do we need in order to successfully predict whether a branch is taken or
not? And where is it going if it's taken? Branch prediction needs to
work using only the knowledge of where we fetched the current instruction from.
And what we needed to guess is the PC of the next instruction to fetch. So
branch predictor must correctly guess, is this a branch?
If not, then it's certainly not taken. If it is a branch, is it taken?
And if it is a taken branch, what is the target PC? Where is this branch going?
These two decisions really can be boiled down to one which is.
Is this a taken branch? It doesn't matter if we have a non-branch instruction,
or a non-taken branch instruction. In both cases, we just fetch
the instruction that follows the branch in memory. So the only thing we
really need to decide is whether this a taken branch, or something else.